en cette période de fin d'année on vous
présente ce soir quelques conseils
fiscaux ou à retenir avant le 31
décembre
on le fait avec charles un 2009 il est
fiscaliste chez io groupe financier on
le retrouve dans nos studios de québec
bonsoir monsieur villeneuve
bonsoir madame st-arnaud on va commencer
d'abord avec le régime enregistré
d'épargne-invalidité le riz à quoi est
ce qu'il faut penser d'ici le 31
décembre
oui j'ai amené avec moi cinq cadeaux
fiscaux auxquels il faut penser en fin
d'année le premier le régime enregistré
d'épargne-invalidité le mei qui
s'adresse pas aux personnes qui
bénéficient du crédit d'impôt pour
personnes handicapées c'est un régime
qui font généreux en termes de
subventions si on cotise 1500 $ dans ce
régime
on peut aller chercher jusqu'à 3500 $ de
subventions
il ya même la possibilité de demander
dès versement rétroactif allant jusqu'à
dix mille 500 $ et les subventions sont
disponibles jusqu'à temps que le
bénéficiaire et 49 ans au 31 décembre
alors il faut vraiment maximiser
l'utilisation de ces subventions là
malheureusement au québec
trois corps des personnes qui pourraient
être admissibles au à eux ils n'ont
toujours pas ouvert de régime
donc c'est très c'est très malheureux et
on est en dessous de la moyenne
canadienne
sans compter que beaucoup de québécois
qui ne réclament pas le crédit d'impôt
pour personnes handicapées est-ce qu'il
faut se rappeler c'est que secret du lot
ne rien avoir avec la capacité à
travailler on peut travailler et avoir
ce crédit d'impôt là et il ya même la
possibilité d'aller le chercher
rétroactivement pendant dix ans donc
vraiment un cadeau fiscal à considérer
donc à une somme à cotiser avant le 31
décembre si je comprends bien oui pour
maximiser les subventions phénomène
similaire pour leur tirer vraiment
enregistré d'épargne-études qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire pour en profiter au
maximum
exactement le deuxième cadeau le régime
enregistré d'épargne-études alors vous
les subventions au minimum ses 30%
on peut cotiser jusqu'à 5000 $ à
l'intérieur est allé chercher 1500
dollars de subventions mais il ya
certains critères par exemple si vous
n'avez jamais ouvert de régime et que
votre enfant par exemple va avoir 15 ans
au 31 décembre
il vous reste à peine quelques jours le
monde rires votre régime est maximisé
les subventions et pour ceux qui
trouvent que la somme et et beaucoup qui
ont connaissant mal
il ya des prêts régime et par une étude
qui sont très intéressants et les bons
d'études
on n'a pas besoin d'être indolore pour
en bénéficier bon alors là aussi il faut
quand même agir rapidement le bon même
chose pour le supplément de revenu
garanti le srg deux choses à penser
le réclamer et le bonifier expliquez
nous oui exactement ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le supplément de revenu
garanti c'est une ied fiscales destinées
aux aînés à faible revenu ça peut aller
jusqu'à dix mille six cents pour un
célibataire et jusqu à 6400 pour un
couple dont les deux sont âgés de 65 ans
et plus malheureusement il ya à peu près
10 9 % des personnes qui sont
admissibles au supplément de revenu
garanti qui ne l'ont pas loin et en
termes de nombre de personnes c'est près
de 445 1000 canadiens oui il ya une
procédure automatique d'inscription qui
est en branle présentement mais ce n'est
pas tout le monde
admissibles qui vont être
automatiquement inscrits donc j'invite
les gens à faire leurs devoirs
maintenant c'est comment et monsieur
hervé 9 pardon on s'inscrit de quelle
manière
la meilleure façon moi je voulais faire
et je vous répondrai avec à votre
conseiller ça risque d'être votre père
noël pour pousser pour cette mesure là
puisqu'il faut savoir c'est aussi être
en mesure de le demander mais de le
bonifier
parce que si votre venue en demande par
exemple si vous retirez derrière vous
pouvez perdre votre supplément de revenu
garanti à compter de 65 ans c'est pour
ça qu'il ya eu une des stratégies c'est
de retirer serrières avant l'année
civile de ses 65 ans en fait c'est une
planification afin pour les personnes
âgées de 60 à 64 ans au 31 décembre et
le montant ainsi retiré on paie l'impôt
en retrait on l'investît ans et lille
compte d'épargné libre d'impôt
d'ailleurs dans deux semaines on va
pouvoir y investir jusqu'à 70 milles
s'il n'y avait jamais contribué et les
retraites futures n'engendreront aucun
impact négatif sur le supplément de
revenu garanti
cette stratégie là peut permettre
d'aller chercher pour certaines
personnes jusqu'à 2000 $ par année donc
un beau cadeau fiscal
encore une fois aller chercher mais il
faut que ce soit bien plein de fibres
considérable donc on va parler du fonds
enregistré de revenu de retraite le
faire pour ceux qui auront 71 ans le 31
décembre autres cadeaux dont
les particularités dans ce cas si
monsieur intervenants oui dans le fond
le fonds enregistré de revenu de
retraite premièrement ceux qui ont 61 71
ans au 31 décembre dépêchez-vous pour
transférer vos reer en ferr
mais pour ceux qui ont envie de moins de
71 ans par exemple de plus de 65 ans il
ya une possibilité d'aller chercher un
crédit pour revenu de pension
mais pour avoir le secret dit ça prend
des revenus de pension alors pour ceux
qui n'ont pas de fonds de pension afin
d'avoir un revenu de pension admissible
retraire hier ça ne fonctionne pas donc
il faut passer par le faire donc les
personnes ce qu'il pourrait faire c'est
de retirer l'équivalent du montant du
crédit d'impôt en rire
le maître enfers puis le retirer ou non
dans certains cas on peut retirer
jusqu'à 2000 $ sans payer d'impôt en
faisant passer leur et leurs enfants
comme vous disiez le conseiller peut
être un bon allié dans ce club parce
qu'ils aient plusieurs manipulations à
faire là cela dit les huit ans cotant
demande des titres pour réclamer des
pertes en capital pour les portefeuille
non enregistré le mon cinquième mon
cinquième cadeau c'est pour ceux qui ont
des seins portefeuille non enregistré
donc au régime et qui ont essuyé des
pertes au courant des derniers mois il
est encore temps il nous reste encore
quelques jours ouvrables pour venir
matérialiser ses pertes la et pour les
reporter à l'encontre des gains en
capitaux réalisés par exemple cette
année ou au cours des trois années
précédentes donc la liste de choses à
faire pendant le temps des fêtes est
longue monsieur de 29 en plus cons du
fait qu'on pourra les lire votre
dernière bd oui l'aspect des deux
premières mais si je regarde fouillé
dans mon âme on sait que j'ai trouvé un
dernier un dernier cadeau fiscal alors
mon dernier les deux lire et relire
rendez-vous fiscal alors ça permet de
recenser plusieurs conseils fiscaux
parce que justement on ne lui en veux
beaucoup
alors pour être capable de pouvoir s'y
retrouver à traverser ce que ça parle
surtout c'est de l'impact du revenu
supplémentaire les derniers dollars
l'impact fiscal que ça aussi une
initiation aux courbes de claude
laferrière qu'il étudie depuis plus de
20 ans
une manière ludique et amusante je
remercie pour tout ça fait plaisir
joyeuse favori